hang on a second there gang before we
get the show started the keep it moving
2021 tour
is in full swing as you know yeah we
have some additions
sure we have some announcements kippy
straighten them out
guys we're coming to providence rhode
island august 11th uh we're going to be
in boston massachusetts august 12th
shaolin should be in new brunswick new
jersey august 25th
jersey stress factory we're going to be
in timonium maryland
outside baltimore at magooby's uh-oh on
august 26th
then the big thing moon tower comedy
festival
we're gonna be there at the fest at the
fest couple of festy boys
uh that's gonna be at the end of
september on september 23rd 24th 25th
also another big announcement we're
going to be at skankfest
houston uh that's going to be nov
november 5th 6th 7th plus we're going to
be adding more dates
it's going to be boncos get some tickies
it's going to be a good time can't wait
to see you there
welcome to another exciting edition of
are
you garbage the show where you find out
if your favorite comedians are classy
individuals
or absolute trash now
here are your hosts kevin ryan and h
foley hey everybody out there
and welcome back to everybody's favorite
new podcast
this is r.u garbage it's a little show
we sit down with your favorite comedians
we found if they grow up to be classy
yeah or if they're just a
big old piece of trash take two i'm your
host stage foley coming at you
on a beautiful day we're down here at
antony's basement a little concerning
what's up
coming downstairs i saw in the kitchen
spoons
there's a spoon like an ice cream party
or something what are you thinking
i don't think so okay it was a bent
spoon a bent
could have been really hard ice cream i
hate when that happens
uh no it said they were they were a
teaspoon they're measuring spoons
she's actually making us uh some nice
tray of lemon squares which i thought
was nice
you ever have her cooking uh i don't
know i mean
she cooked me up a couple of hot doses
before but
her narcan and cream is fantastic folks
my co-host is coming at you
across the table uh that means this is a
family episode
we're circling the wagon feel like it's
been a while it's been a while a couple
of episodes a couple epis we got some
some questions to get to
just the fam on this one uh this
gentleman
is the ceo cfo ceo
of i'm everything are you garbage um
he is uh he's an international
businessman really he has a multitude of
offshore accounts
with uh different um european banking
institutions deutsche bank
do ya couple kevin james ryan everybody
hey gang happy to be here thanks for
tuning in as always please make sure you
rate review subscribe on itunes although
that's going out the window no one cares
about that anymore which one
itunes my tune yeah it's whatever
i appreciate all these reviews they're
switching it up that's steve jobs keeps
you on your toes
and then youtube.com you can get a full
video hd video
there and as you know those numbers are
true to roof
true the roof not be it and then but
what about
i mean what about this patreon.com
i don't i don't know if you can hear the
[ __ ] viking stove we got up here
cause this thing's [ __ ] cooking daddy
oh open a cage
thank you so much for the [ __ ]
support on patreon uh we [ __ ] love
every single one of you ever watched the
show listen to the show tweet the show
send it to a friend bought a shirt
anything a deck of cards the [ __ ]
patreon
subscribed on youtube we [ __ ] love
everybody thank you please no we're
blowing the money as fast as we get it
and that's a promise we make to you
yes right yeah oh yeah
that's my niece birthday party you know
you laid a couple of fuzz
he's all caked up over here yeah how
much you dropped
and how old is this this young lady ah
turned nine turned nine yeah yeah
yeah let me guess you probably get a guy
like you let me now listen i had already
bought her oh here we go
guys hold on i bought her a present a
couple months a couple weeks ago when i
was home got her some dollies and stuff
like that
and her parents said no don't make do
not do that
but you know of course i got to show up
i'm sure sure family there
sure uh let me think ultimate face throw
too because they did a presentation of
presents
she sat there in a little chair opening
them up uncle hanks was last i pretend
like i know it was going i don't know
where is it i thought it was behind the
tree whatever
a guy like you guys currently wearing a
sleep shirt from
ralph lauren uh [ __ ] saleswoman at
dxl man
[ __ ] piss me off um guy like you
nine-year-old niece you know you got a
couple of bucks now you're doing all
right we got us a pretty successful
podcast
you know i know what you're making a guy
like you
probably gave 400. 400. yeah
get eddie what do you mean you didn't
give her 400. 400.
she's a little he's [ __ ] nine he's a
little princess
this
give me your address i'll send her the
other two that you [ __ ] shorted her
you [ __ ] hey this is from uncle kippy
gang how about a nice quick shout out to
our producer extraordinaire yeah i
forgot we didn't even bring in there he
said i didn't i didn't that's why i'm
your boy and i'm a professional he's the
magic man he makes us all look good we
love him
you love him give it up for t-bone
mcmuffin is that toby mcmullen everybody
what's
up dudes hey pal hey there t-bone yeah
about two more minutes of no intro for
me the comment section would have been
going nuts
they're fighting they ate t-mode it's
drama
t-bones dead man ah gang this is a
family episode thank you so much for
tuning in with this
um before we get to the questions i hate
you got something i got a couple of
things i wanted to true by you
okay you can't have an advance
you get paid from the rest of us dude
can i get that 200 for my niche now is
you have a hundred well crisp undies
though
crisp yeah fresh got them in a grocery
store
if you're going if you're giving cash
it's got to be hundies unless you're
like jam i get it whatever but
yeah stack of 20s ain't bad though
otherwise they smell like a [ __ ]
pizza place or something you know the
delivery boy had them before you
get out of here you never get money back
you're like what the [ __ ]
parmigiano the [ __ ] you doing with this
hit the bricks chris bundys i pegged you
as a chili's gift card kind of guy
now come on what uncle hank are you
kidding me i'm [ __ ] all-star
class all the way whatever you need
small stuff i'm good big stuff
i disappear i'm aware i've gotten i'm
yet to get a birthday present from you
out then when was your birthday august
wow happy birthday i mean well you
missed 10 of them
[ __ ] look he's starting now jesus christ
you're like my dad
a couple of scratchers um a
friend of mine was discussing a trip
that they have coming up and
they were they were saying that one
thing they really want to do
is they want to go see some it was some
kind of chocolate factory or something
like that
and my question is friend of yours
it's going to a chocolate factory
foley's gonna get stuck in a pipe like
augustus
i gotta go cut them out that's that
[ __ ] chocolate river when i was a kid
that's why they call your pants
that was your underwear after after gym
class
oh i got the big man's number today
let's go
um when we were staying in the hotel
together
i had done some business in the bathroom
and i had to make that's why you're not
a lot that's why we don't that's why we
don't stay together well i had to make
sure i flushed multiple times because i
had [ __ ] demon claw marks at the
bottom
i've seen it's like dragging him back to
hell once again goddamn
it's like a goddamn exorcism
you gotta have a priest read your shit's
last right
man no we didn't start turning upside
down when i walk into the
it bathroom cold it's all the flies in
here
do you think it's trashy probably
welcome back ladies and gentlemen do you
think this is something
yeah okay no do you think it's trashy to
go to the factory
any fat like you know like oh we got a
tour of the factory
are you a factory tour i've done well i
told you
way back in the early days of the pod my
mom took us to the sock factory
that was a thing i remember to get she
was picking up money
i don't know what was happening i just
remember being like we were in the bad
part of town too we were like [ __ ]
it was like yeah but it wasn't for a
tour it was to buy socks for [ __ ]
i think it might have been a combination
of both what it was in like
bristol or pendle or one of those
[ __ ] levita it was somewhere well it
was strategy
somewhere the wrong side of the tracks
i remember not wanting to get out i
remember that much not wanting to get
out
of the car oh my god i thought you meant
you were in love with the place
can i live here next to the tubes i just
never been like [ __ ] this place
um i'm talking like if you go to the
guinness factory i did the guinness the
guinness is whatever
the guinness i i've told you this i i
think i'm sure i have at some point
i went to the guinness factory and you
go to like the [ __ ] 90-minute ordeal
these are barley this is hops we're
whatever i get which stinks but they do
have like the highest the guinness
factor has like the highest
uh bar it's the highest
the tallest bar in ireland or something
it's they have this big 360 degree
view of them it's like at the bigger the
top of the building like going to a roof
how do you reach up and get your beer
oh my god you are so bad what do you
mean the bar
itself is tall that's what i'm saying
how do you
are you [ __ ] with me no what do you
mean you have to be [ __ ] with me
you said you're the tallest bar yeah the
barcelo's like barber's chairs you pump
them up and it raises oh the bar is on
the roof it's like the highest bar
oh the that's the not the tallest bar
well i mean
the toilet would be like you're leaving
no of the tens of thousands of people
that are listening to this you have to
be the only one that interpreted that
nah
did you think that at first yes oh my
god
i think i meant to say tallest building
with a bar i think i said tallest
building with a bar
you didn't you said tallest ball by the
way it stinks whatever
yeah no so i got up there and i'm like i
lost my ticket
and i was like like on the [ __ ] walk
and you redeem it for a free
for a free beer and they were like i was
like i didn't have i was like i get two
beers
like you can't buy them here i'm like
what the [ __ ]
like i just watch how it was [ __ ]
made for 90 minutes like a jerk off i
can't get a [ __ ] frosty pint
let's go [ __ ] let's go timmy yeah and
then i
so i just had left and had to go buy a
guinness elsewhere it stinks i only
wanted to go for the
to have a beer at the highest point in
dublin at a bar or whatever like
that was the only thing plus i was alone
i had to kill time during the day
you can only [ __ ] you can only
world's smallest empanadas
[Laughter]
it was a play on the world's tallest
yeah i got i mean i get to play i don't
understand
why empanadas i mean we weren't in
mexico
what are you talking about oh my gosh
who doesn't love an empanada
okay i don't think they're at the bar in
ireland i don't think the guinness
factory serving empanadas
could be ah i think it's trashy yeah
i do i agree okay but what if you go to
like the mclaren factory that's a little
that's that's a little different i mean
even still like
if i worked there i wouldn't want a
bunch of [ __ ] bozos let's watch
the work work there but sure at the
guinness factory so we're going to start
tours in here i don't know what you're
talking about
top tier patrons get to come in and
[ __ ] talk on the mic for a couple of
minutes
kind of page walking around okay i got a
[ __ ] wax t-bone over there
he's bombing uh yeah it's trashy i
i wouldn't i wouldn't do it factory's
lame going to the factory we're gonna
thank you yeah give a [ __ ]
i think i guess like if you went to like
hirsch the hershey factory maybe that's
thanks
yeah yeah i mean that's what i'm saying
i understand
i could understand you ever been to the
coca-cola factory
no been to the cocaine factory i used to
work in a chocolate factory
yeah but that was afterwards it was jay
weren't producing chocolate right there
i thought you were skimming the place oh
what the [ __ ]
jesus christ we're gonna have to beat
that you and your dirtbag old man
all right we gotta we're gonna literally
have to cut that sorry
dude the coca-cola factory is insane
they have all the different types of
coke from all around the world
so they taste different for each other
yeah yeah yeah so in russia it tastes
like rocks
and then you know america it's extra
sweet or whatever this jelly bean get
out of here [ __ ] different cokes come
on man
it's crazy go to a factory uh yeah no
one's saying we're agreeing
on it all right i thought he was just
working in that rock bit
working on his russian rock bit i'm
gonna i'm gonna find a way to shovel
this in today
uh i had a pin in bed out of the train
looking across looking across it a guy
in a bootleg paid in full shirt
oh that's good um yeah
i wouldn't do it is this you i think
you're talking about this
no i'm not no no i don't i don't go to
factories i wouldn't go to the factory
okay what if it was like are you a
museum guy
muse yeah yeah like a nice museum nice
nice painting
like that a nice paint i like a nice
painting painting
painting painting or a statue i like a
nice statue
or a triptych all right for you art
history majors out there
sure you know i like stained glass i
like a bust
so much as the next guy like i'm tossed
i can tell poking out of that [ __ ]
polo sleepwear shirt
i don't like the planetariums though
they're kind of [ __ ] whack
you don't really see anything like the
thing that they got over there next to
the natural history museum on the west
side
you walk in it's just like pictures of
[ __ ] like what are we doing
yeah i don't know you can't get a
[ __ ] asteroid in here none of that
asteroids
they have a couple but they don't have
enough yeah they have fragments of
asteroids
different worlds galaxies okay i mean
this guy came in this guy goes home for
the weekend comes back all goofballs
the [ __ ] are they feeding you down there
patty what are you doing
mostly paint yeah this guy's all [ __ ]
hopped up
um all right let's get it do you want to
get us some questions do you have any
more
[ __ ] factory combos you want to talk
about wanted to get your opinion i
apologize
um all right this one is this is you
know i like to start off
uh what uh what a good one this is what
we call a bez a home run
this is from daniel uh hey guys i'm new
here love your stuff have you ever made
us have you ever made yourself a
sandwich to eat while you were making
yourself a better sandwich 100
that is a [ __ ] brilliant that's an
observation pro move
they make the half you make like a hair
i typically go the heel so it's got a
little bit of density i'd love to hear
yeah that's one big heel guy you a heel
guy
no oh you're nuts [ __ ] that's your
youth as you get older you appreciate it
you're happy you appreciate the end
you do yeah it's like remember when
you're like a strong beer
it's the ipa of bread remember when you
were a k i remember a couple of times
and my mom was pretty good but i
remember like once or twice
you know she forgot to run to the store
or something like that i wasn't aware of
it
i get to the lunch table you give me a
heads up on the way to the bus
we can work something out you can get
out in front of it make you make fun of
yourself before you get there
well that's [ __ ] fat guy 101. yeah
dude set me up
[ __ ] pulled out two of them not one
but two it was like i was eating a
peanut butter jelly on a hamburger bun
[ __ ] him get out of here this is a
ceiling tile sandwich
yeah i went home a drop ceiling sandwich
i went on that day i was like never let
this happen again this
this doesn't happen again yeah still
like the sandwich
sure i mean grown boy
it needs calcium yeah but i need i need
my rich flour what else
loves the end um as that's what i'll do
now if i'm making
you know oh it depends on what i'm
making
and it depends you know no it could be
tuna it could be turkey it doesn't
matter
i know i'm making i'm making a happy
sure but i don't [ __ ] we don't
we don't keep bread in the house the bra
i don't i try to lay off it because
i do enough damage when i'm [ __ ] out
of the house you know what i mean so
i don't keep it in the house she don't
eat it like a pigeon in the park
oh man i'm going at it with a raccoon
um you ever see that when you go by
somebody's yard there's just pieces of
bread there for the birds
jesus my stepdad does that he feeds the
squirrels out whole pieces
like if like bread like you know if like
bread's getting old or they're not going
to finish everybody goes out and throws
it and throws it in the backyard
stale bread in those bags man knock you
out
yeah yeah yes i've had to explain that
to my friends like what's this bag of
bread doing with like
it's like next to like my step dad's
wallet and
this stuff loves his sandwiches like
this bread's hard as a rock like dude
it's for the squirrels don't touch it
it's worth it
yeah big happy guy when i do sandwich
i'm typically doing rolls cause i'm down
i'm either down the shore or i'm you
know i'm at i'm at maz and she knows i'm
coming home
she keeps the sixer amorosos for the kid
kippy loves a long amoroso six pack in
the fridge yeah
[ __ ] get your
so i don't really do bread that much
anymore but yeah for sure of course
you know what the heel is not too bad on
a grilled cheese either keeps the cheese
in there i tell you you get older
you love the the heel is great yeah and
it is fantastic for a [ __ ] for a half
jaw
oh yeah especially if it's that potato
bread real thick
[ __ ] nice on the inside little mayo
little mustard
couple pieces of cheese i know what a
sandwich is
don't forget the pickle beautiful oh
yeah that's good
love that i love doing when you're
making sandwiches at home when you know
it's
when you spread everything out you got
the hate you got everything out you know
what i mean
you leave the mayo mustard out you're
having a good time the game's on
bag of chips real slice of americana
right there are you talking about
feeding the squirrels where do you fall
on bird feeders
i don't i don't like burr i'm deathly
afraid of birds so i'm going to have to
i'm going to have to say no to this real
tough guy huh yeah
they used to dive bomb toby is that
charlie bronson over there i can't tell
hey sandwich steve relax will you
that's done i have i got it i got a
right to defend myself
and he's back all right let's go this
kid's good
i don't know that bozo was but he's all
right this guy's this new guy he's great
alaska last guy stunk good thing you got
him out of here
i just parked my hair right um garbage
beautiful but garbage i don't know they
never last they get
you ever see a [ __ ] up birdhouse
it looks haunted no but i i got a night
i got a hat
i got a dub says there's about two of
them on your property right now easily
i've put a couple of slumlords over
there i remember the first time my buddy
had one that fed like
it's like sugar water for like
hummingbirds or whatever those are nice
and i didn't
i literally didn't know hummingbirds i
thought they were tropical or whatever i
didn't know i never seen one
dude and we're sitting in my buddy
paul's out back in his pool
and there's a [ __ ] there's two
hummingbirds [ __ ]
i panicked what is he what is he a
disney princess they were
well they had to feed her with like the
sugar water and i didn't know it was
like a [ __ ] it was like two feet
behind me and he sings
these things come in like [ __ ] two
f-16s
[Music]
i [ __ ] lost i jumped in the water
they're hover controlled
they're gonna have to dive bomb to get
me dude i went under
their hover control is fantastic they're
like two drones uh yeah i know [ __ ]
i didn't know that i didn't i didn't
know anything about that i didn't know
they even had them in pennsylvania i
would have had one of those i love
hummingbirds yeah i didn't i do i
literally thought they were in the
amazon or like the rainfall i didn't
know where the [ __ ] they were i swear to
god until [ __ ]
we were in high school nope
not not [ __ ] with those things man
gang support for all you garbage is
brought to you by our good friends
over there at manscaped and when i'm
talking about manscape what am i talking
about
talking about the lawnmower four one
point
nope two point nope 4.4.0
baby baby this thing is fantastic
it purrs like it's got a rolls-royce
engine in it
it's just it feels like quality it's got
the light on it
trimmed it right up real nice if you're
not taking care of your downstairs
you're a bozo especially with this heat
yeah you gotta you gotta you gotta you
gotta weed the beds
sure uh they have the best in men's
below the waist
grooming champion of the world baby is
manscaped but it comes down to it
um you get the [ __ ] it's got a light on
it it's waterproof the whole nine yards
i don't know about you guys i mean this
time of year the summer you got to be
taking care of the business down there
i do do it in the shower too because i
like goes down the drain
and i collect and it's not me yeah yeah
i use it on my face i'm crazy
i don't give a [ __ ] i use it right on my
face i trim up it gets me down here real
nice
does cut close it's nice ah do why not
um
also i back in the day i used to use
blade and cream
like a fl like a like a wacko really
blade and cream down there you
pull out the shaft shimmy it up a little
it's dangerous couple of nicks and guts
down there
not too good sweeney todd yeah so check
out the lawnmower 4.0
uh it's got different lengths so you can
customize the trim that you're looking
for
um you get free 20 all you get 20 off
and free shipping with the promo code
garbage at manscape.com that's 20
off free shipping at manscape.com use
the promo code garbage
unlock your confidence and always use
the right tools for the job
uh and that's with a well-designed sleek
and optimized trimmer that makes shaving
shaving time your favorite time in the
bathroom perfect way to say it that's
some that's some good copyright oh yeah
guys uh manscape.com promo code garbage
gang are you garbage is brought to you
by
movement let's talk about them top
notches guys
top-notch operation man couple of
dreamers couple of college kids
couple of dropouts yeah thought they
could do better in the watch market
and they absolutely hit a fantastic home
run
they sent us a couple beautiful got the
watch we got the sunglasses
beautiful beautiful products yeah they
moved into sunglasses
unbelievable fresh they wanted to make
things that were quality
quality product that looked fancy but it
was still
under a decent budget sure and they
accomplished that
to such a degree out of the park here's
this what you ready to get your hair
blown back on this one hit me you go to
movement right now what's that
site-wide sale stop it telling you right
now how much you think
five percent five percent sure that'd be
great keep going
keep going fifteen now twenty
ah twenty five twenty eight percent what
toby pull the plug holy cow these guys
are bonkers over there
yeah guys and all joe all jokes aside
though the watches are beautiful the
sunglasses are beautiful they look
cool they feel cool they feel like you
know it feels
doesn't it feels awesome no yeah it's
good sorry i'm excited i'm sorry
it's high quality stuff i'm excited it's
high quality stuff i got the glasses you
got the watch because you're a watch guy
everybody knows i'm a new glasses guy
now
i'm rocking the shades real cool real
cool color real cool lenses
my wife got the the blue the to block
out the blue lights
nice yeah um the
the premium blue light glasses they
probably so if you're looking at the
screen and stuff
um it's good stuff uh it's a perfect
gift for family or friends
movement is going all out for their
eighth birthday and this is their
biggest sale of the year take advantage
of these price points before they go
because they ain't gonna stick around
forever celebrate eight years of
movement with 28
off site wide like the big man said so
don't miss movement's biggest sale of
the year go to mvmt.com
garbage one more time that's 28
off storewide at mvmt.com
garbage join a movement
stamps.comstamps.com
why didn't i know earlier about
stamps.com cause you're
a bozo i am a bozo and i've done a lot
of waiting around in the post office
stamps.com has changed all that danger
we made the call we had the cards made
we sent the cards out
using stamps.com amazing yeah they save
thousands of businesses sure time and
money
we're a small business owner if you're a
small business owner
you need stamps.com yeah guys you can
mail and ship
anytime anywhere right from your
computer send letters packages and you
pay less
a lot less with discounted rates from
usps and ups
ups too that's great all you need is a
computer a printer the internet bada
bing bada boom you can do it in your car
you do it in your rv your house your
apartment
your barn wherever you live you can do
it it's easy peasy like the big man said
we sent out all the cards over thousands
of decks of cards we said we were in
here printing it out by the bing body
one day we did like 500 i think we did
it start to finish
in under an hour it starts cooking that
printer honestly it's cooking printers
start spitting them out bing bang boom
you're up and you're up and running it's
easy
peasy um they offer deals that you can't
get anywhere else like 40
off usps and up to 66 percent off ups
shipping rates what are we even talking
about people bonkos uh and with their
switch and save feature you can quickly
compare carriers to find the best rates
every single time i love that stop going
stop wasting time by going to the post
office go to stamps.com instead
there is no risk and with our promo code
garbage you'll get a special offer that
includes a four week trial plus free
postage in a
digital scale no long-term commitments
or contracts you can cancel any time
there's nothing to cancel you just easy
peasy if you don't use it you don't use
it whatever
when you use it use it we have it
sitting over there when we need it bada
bing bada boom plug it in
you're up and running it's easy just go
to stamps.com click the microphone at
the top of the home page type in garbage
that's stamps.com
promo code garbagestamps.com never go to
the post office
again now back
the squirrels always get them i'm afraid
of the squirrels that's the big thing i
love squirrels i'm afraid of creatures
and critters man
no my wife's like oh look at the
scrambling this is a new york city
[ __ ] squirrel
it's like these ain't like pet the
squirrels this ain't the country
they're i like those squirrels in the
city no
yeah cute little squirrels running
around central park cute little squirrel
right right i only possibly got drugs on
them
that's what i'm talking about no i don't
[ __ ] i do not [ __ ] with them i like i'll
go out of my way
if one like is jumping around i did see
that uh they caught
uh komodo dragons are creatures
hummingbirds are not
creatures i don't [ __ ] with komodo
dragons or those those
lizards that swim in the water that look
like mini godzilla's
get the [ __ ] out of here i don't care
where that sandals is i ain't [ __ ]
staying nothing
do you ever see them they jump in a pool
they'll come at ya what oh
yeah i don't even like a komodo dragon
or just a lizard commodore
you go with it that's kimono i mean i
know wildwood's bad but goddamn
i mean i know it's not avalon but we
don't have [ __ ] komodo dragon they
got sunglasses on
the dragons they're bad kids
that was okay tattoos something what
were you talking what jumps in the pool
with you
like the monitor lizards or whatever
yeah yeah
no i can't do it i like the little
jaundice no
what the little salamanders florida
they're cute little geckos they'll get
in the pool
i [ __ ] i've ruined a family vacation
that way
no [ __ ] way i don't [ __ ] with lizards
snakes
serpents nothing dude
i don't [ __ ] with them nope the other
thing i don't like about about hawaii is
uh
is that they have centipedes there you
are oh yeah no i saw one of those in
colombia
had a [ __ ] had like lobster claws on it
i'm like what are we doing here
assistant safe go back inside cigar in
its mouth
yeah no thank you i don't
i don't like animals dog domesticated
ones i'll do
cats whatever what you love it i love
animals
not animals like wild animals like a
wild horse you wouldn't appreciate the
beauty of a wild stallion
running through the pasture i mean when
do you see that
i got a better chance of seeing a
[ __ ] kimono dragon check out
yellowstone on paramount tv it's a
pretty good show
that yeah whatever that's fine a horse
isn't gonna [ __ ] you know run up and
start nibbling don't [ __ ] you up i used
to get scared of her because they kick
you i when you walk behind them
oh i don't know if i ever told you i
went to this [ __ ] after school thing
because my mom
so it was like kindergarten was a sock
factory
if i was doing third shift it was after
preschool was like preschool was only
like nine to 12 or whatever right there
was like a morning shift and an
afternoon shift or kindergarten whatever
the [ __ ] it was
and for whatever reason they had like
another place a second location you
could go to
not breezy point rainbow academy i don't
know what the [ __ ] it was
but they had a horse there and i was
like oh you get to play with the horse
dude and we went up to feed this thing
apples
and you ever see the foam that [ __ ]
forms around a horse's mouth when he's
eaten
oh i can still smile
dude i was like this thing so dean is
like six being like get this thing the
[ __ ] away from me
is it snack time yet what are we doing
here
[ __ ] i gotta feed this guy my apple
[ __ ] dying over here
yeah oh dude the [ __ ] [ __ ] it's like
buddy get a napkin
there's chicks here man come on i'm
trying
[Laughter]
ah horses are gross dude
[ __ ] clean yourself up
ah man i remember that being on like
doing like the great adventure safari
where you drive around
that's garbage too oh i did that and the
[ __ ] monkey started ripping my
windshield
off my windshield what the [ __ ] sick
hey man those
[Laughter]
yeah i got hemmed up into six flags i
thought i was [ __ ] johnny cool guy
nope [ __ ] zebra came up started
[ __ ] chewing my
my stripes and [ __ ] man
we were at a zoo in dc and my whole
family
they're sitting there
holy [ __ ] to see in washington dc you go
to a zoo we went for lunch
i mean you got all the monuments the
white house the pentagon
you guys are [ __ ] staring at the
gorillas yeah these monkeys were in the
thing and they were just looking at the
book he's like hey you're gonna finish
that
they're crying or sweating or something
laughing
ah monkey was swinging around [ __ ]
swings right towards the glass
takes the dump mid-air
my aunt's like two feet away from it
just like they're beautiful
yeah right on the [ __ ] i thought
uh down in cape may county uh
like why i would take the zoo down there
for sure we went to see the lions and we
have a picture i gotta get
i gotta get my hands on the [ __ ]
picture it's at my aunt paddy's house
it's early 90s probably like 92
and it's me and all my cousins my
brother and we look
like [ __ ] every different version of
joe dirt i mean dude there's [ __ ]
i'm talking the high side it timeline
joe
tough look and we were banging there's a
lion's sleeve we were banging on the
[ __ ] k and he pissed he woke up took
two walks back and forth like oh look at
him comes over dude and a fire hose
of [ __ ] yellow stanky lion p
all over us all over
until right behind my hand i was like
you ain't [ __ ] getting me dude
keep your head on i keep my head on a
[ __ ] swivel around live
man but on the safari they come and they
stick their faces in the window
and when you're a little kid you don't
realize they're going to have like you
know
slobber and chill over them yeah
i'm not going to be able to eat for the
rest of the day that's
tough oh god papa certs
joe campbell [ __ ] relax yeah i don't
that's not for me none of that's for me
uh great question about the
i imagine you're a birdhouse family
though right you a birdhouse family no
[ __ ] way
no there's [ __ ] all over your lawn
what yeah we don't we don't we're not
condors what do you mean it's [ __ ]
bird [ __ ] not a pterodactyl
you're not getting fined by the
homeowners association i know i don't we
we never attracted animals
i mean now the squirrels but like we
don't really bring them in keep them at
a distance
over at the neighbors you know what i
mean
you know the deer there's a lot of deer
now yeah deer like just in the backyard
well if you're like sitting in a chair
in the backyard they'll come up like
[ __ ]
20 feet away from me yeah i think deer
are beautiful uh
but yeah the lyme disease i don't go
near them i don't like it
i mean you're not making out with him
are you they're ticks everywhere oh
you're
nuts get that [ __ ] not gonna jump at ya
the ticks do no they don't not the deer
i mean how close are you getting to the
deer that a tick's gonna jump back
doesn't matter that they're everywhere
people aren't getting lyme disease by
[ __ ] hanging out with deer
the ticks are all over the place i get
you i don't like that
yeah so it has nothing to do with
getting close to the deer
your initial thing was i don't get close
to the deer because i don't want lyme's
disease i guess that makes sense
hmm look at that you turn me around
i literally don't know what side either
one of us are on at this point
um all right this one's from joshua do
you jiggle the coin
the coins or keys in your front pockets
oh yeah that's a
big love it big move i was right when
you got a car
you had to flex that sure it's got my
keys do the flip
yeah oh you should do the flip with the
laminate too the lanyard
lanyard yeah dude if you had if you had
like a [ __ ] some sort of college
lanyard when you were in high school
yeah bike lacrosse [ __ ] twirling
around
keys around the neck backwards was a big
thing oh was it
ever you couldn't do it forward that was
like his device of a one strap two strap
on a school bag
you had to go backwards cool guys went
backwards wait say that wait what's one
strap two strap
you got one straps cool no what two
it was it changed when i it's it was one
strap
it was all through the 90s no book bag
was cool in the 90s just have your books
under here
what yeah what are you showing what are
you in greece what are you talking about
bully's got his books and a belt
what like dobie gillis walking around
that's a deep gut i mean
would you would you walk like this with
him in your [ __ ] you got pencil
sticking out i would have my my
my wrestling bag or whatever bag you
know for like
you know change of clothes sports stuff
i never carried any [ __ ] books around
really [ __ ] academic like you yeah
just it was always cool to have like one
or two books just
in your things well we said we sell far
cool got you
guys i'm going to be cool real quick
[ __ ] wearing pajama shirts right now
i never got a jan
sport or any of that stuff oh we had a
jan sport yeah
transport kid um but it was
it was in elementary school it was one
that was cool one was cool the 90s one
was cool
then in high school you did two you did
one you were a
dork two became cool i feel like your
generation is when they started really
packing those [ __ ]
school bags out and like they would like
get like there was so many books some
some girl walking out with like so many
yeah where the straps are ripping and
stuff
that's not i mean that's that's not
that's the exception to the rule yeah
that's not the average guys walking
around with every textbook they have
right i could never do that [ __ ] i hate
carrying stuff around like that would
you keep it loose what was your locker
situation like i imagine foley was just
like a bad lawyer it's just papers
spilling out
it's a mini bridge
open it up fog comes out we have dry ice
in here
anybody want any snickers or anything i
keep it cool hot towel for anyone
lemon water um our school had uh
you had one you had your locker and then
above your locker you had a little
square one
little john that had a little a little
dead man switch inside that's
the second time you said dead man switch
you said today
i know but before yeah you said your
toilet had one
we made the joke that it was an injector
scene
you got a little switch there to pop
open the other one that's where you put
a couple of things
and yes it was usually gross but it was
always great when you cleaned out your
locker
that or your desk when you were a little
kid and we really cleaned out your desk
made everything real nice
stole a couple of pencils from somewhere
you ever get your hands in the [ __ ]
in the what's it called room supplies
supply room yeah
oh man a supply we went in elementary
school a good
night strawberry erasers for everybody
oh man no you never did that no
i don't think they had they had like a
clock i mean who wanted to steal pencils
they have nice fresh pencils just
knocking over the cafeteria for the cash
register i'm not [ __ ]
i'm letting you guys do the petty crimes
i'm going for the cash
going for the strong box [ __ ] are we
doing here
go for the school store or something
something worth doing the time
i'm not gonna serve a nickel for a
couple of [ __ ] weeble wobbles
my senior year in high school uh we had
this kid on our wrestling team real
tough kid real crazy kid
we were wrestling to school it was a
saturday afternoon we were killed we
were beating them like a million to
nothing
these kids in the [ __ ] school store
cleaning up
yeah we got caught robbing the school
store that always happens that was
always the kid that kid was always on
the wrong side of the track
yeah school store was great though love
all
i hated learning all right but i loved
all that stuff i loved like all the i
mean i like learning some things i was a
terrible student i guess it's a better
way to put it
but i loved like new books and new
pencils and new pens and
erasers and like all that kind of stuff
the stuff was great
trapper keepers very cool with all that
stuff smelled i just liked the way
everything smelled
did you chew your pencils oh yeah chewed
my pencils
i used to take my pens apart like they
were like they were nuclear bombs they
like
put it back together yeah [ __ ] it good
try to do a blindfolded
mm-hmm you learn something new every day
there you go trapper keeper guy what i
never
guessed really you they were huge
yeah eighties five star when five star
came through that was it yeah it was a
fight you had to have five star
otherwise you hit the [ __ ]
yeah the trapper keepers they weren't
assembled well
but i had one with optimus prime on the
cover [ __ ] sick
lasts for like two weeks and they get
all broken up but wing it though
yeah they don't make them like they used
to they don't make them like they used
to kippy
truer words were never spoken i really
would have picked you for a better
student to be honest with you moving on
really i was good at english no you're
not
you just said go to museums to see
paintings or you say
literature i was good with literature
like poems and stuff
i like that stuff you know it's good
junior year
mr blanche great teacher great teacher
good job blanche
you are in that chat all right
moving on um this is from jacob
ever tape over the name on a jersey when
the player gets traded and sharpie in
the name of the next bozo
no you see that guy at like flyers games
and [ __ ] how about the guys burning
their jerseys
somebody [ __ ] up in a game or leaves
the city
get out of here with that [ __ ] yeah and
that's bozo stuff can you imagine your
kid
watching you in your backyard burn a
[ __ ]
uh you know tom brady jersey or
something like that
come on man got support you paid 100
bucks for
it gotta support the team it's a
different city
gotta support the team what are you
gonna do at a certain point you just
gotta
like come on what are we doing yeah no i
mean it's definitely do you ever see
your dad burn a jersey
no yeah exactly but tough luck
yeah uh the next one is ever buy a
sports jersey that was blank on the back
to save a couple of bucks
that's a dead giveaway that you're
hemmed up you're hanging out at a
[ __ ] sporting event with a blank
jersey on it i like that more
i like that more to be honest with you
because if you're a grown man
now you're a little kid you get whatever
you want but if you're a grown man and
you've got like
a younger guy's name on it i've never
understood that i mean
i don't have another man's name on my
back it's
so what about a man it's just you know
and you're wearing another player's
thing
i think that you know another player so
in your reality you are also a player
you know what i mean fully all goes the
game suited up
ready for a week of fifth minute yeah
no i think it's okay to have just a
regular jersey especially a baseball one
but if i did i have bryce harper
um this one's just bonkers this is for
mario first time asking ever been shot
or shout out by mistake by
while hunting with your family i mean
you know if your [ __ ] uncle's taking
shots at you thinking you're a [ __ ]
moose or something that's a bad look on
all accounts
that's so true yeah we weren't hunters
either
now petrified yeah
uh this is from preston uh are you
garbage if you only air-conditioned
certain parts of the house
yes you are that's how i
saw the foley's operation sure you got
it most of the 1980s it depends how hot
it is as well
and kind of what equipment you're
working with okay you know what i mean
yeah at our place and if it's if it's
window units
that's understand you keep that [ __ ]
door closed you don't you don't [ __ ]
air condition the hallway
[ __ ] jerk off keep that door closed
yeah we used to
we had one window unit uh at uh the
second house that we lived in when i
lived in wilkes-barre
and i remember one summer it was [ __ ]
boiling
and like we all slept downstairs in the
living room yeah
and my mom put blankets over the like
the
the walkway or the entrance yeah the
entrance way
and we were all stayed in there all
snuggled up all cozy locker
oh yeah
but dude you'd walk out of there you
have to sit down you get dizzy
that's what we so we now we have we have
three
window units in our apartment you have
three
window units yeah wow yeah we're doing
all right i have two
yeah i got three crazy yeah um so my
the way my uh apartment's set up you
walk in and it's straight it's a
straight hallway
to the right is the kitchen and there's
a door on that
a pool like you that like there's a
french door on it we have french doors
in our apartment
there's a french door on that closes our
kitchen and dining
french doors meaning there's windows in
them yeah like the window all right i
was gonna say
if you have a door in your kitchen no
it's a french tool yeah it's if i can i
don't know it's
it's the style of those i understand
yeah so there's
that close so you can close that off
there's one in there because there's
also a dining section in there there's a
kitchen and dining section
dining section listen to this [ __ ]
guy so
breakfast nook whatever you want oh my
god um it always makes me hungry
breakfast nook
thinking nooks and crannies yeah shout
out to thomas i'm gonna start calling
you smuckers because you're jamming up
the works
come on we're having fun here so that
closes off
and then to the left we have the living
room and
like office area and that's got one in
it that also has a french door wait hold
on a second
is there was there is there air
conditioner in the kitchen i forget
yes and one in the living room yes okay
that closes off
and then we have one in the bedroom that
also obviously there's a bedroom so what
the smart play is to turn them all on
open up all the doors
and get the whole place out no we keep
that [ __ ]
bathroom and stuff so dude you walk into
the [ __ ] you walk from the living
room
that hallway is like no man's land why
do you do it that way
don't you like when i like when the
bathroom's air conditioning sure
it's just it doesn't it doesn't fully
cook that well you're better off closing
the door
plus that electric yeah yeah
really well it's a big hallway the
[ __ ] and also like the one in the
living room
is i don't like that okay walking out in
the hallway cooking
yeah well you stay in the way you
[ __ ] stay at home base
you only go for supplies when it's
desperate to stock up before you get in
there
i we talked there was one summer i think
it was two summers ago
i think it was two summers ago remember
i didn't have money for a window unit
or a call yeah i was like we were like
really hemmed up
and i was so poor it was airbnb in my
[ __ ] apartment
remember that yeah and you stayed there
a couple of times
i ran it out to you i sleep on the couch
kevin i want to rent you a spot but you
got to stay there with me four stars
and i remember getting all that was a
box fan
and i put cold water i would like put
cold water in the bathroom and let that
like then the fan thinking it was
and it did a little bit cool off the air
that was coming at you did i remember
hallucinating in the middle of the night
it was so high um yeah it was like my
brain was melting dude for 200 bucks you
come sweat in my bed
wait you were renting that place with no
ac no i got an ac
before i started right now yeah yeah of
course i mean
yeah but it was bad it was that it was
that was the apartment kevin ryan
reality tour
the real kevin ryan you get to work in a
law
you get to have an angry dollar slice of
pizza
go home masturbate furiously then hit
the open mics
you'll be back home by 4 5 a.m
for a nice hot night of sweating well
there was only like two outlets in the
whole apartment
so we had to have the [ __ ] weird we
had to have the extension click an
outdoor extension cord [ __ ] running
from the living room to the bedroom
oh look brilliant question um i don't
know if we've done this one
if i've read this or not uh this is from
nicholas ever install an aftermarket cup
holder in your car
we have talked about spots i remember
that's
i remember we talked about the ashtrays
yeah there's aftermarket ashtrays
any anything those things are like the
suction or the arms or the clips
it's bad you get into an uber sometimes
you're like this is the melody [ __ ]
millennium falcon
just to get over here right home from
[ __ ] cleveland or laguardia the other
day
he put it right in the heap he suctioned
it right in the middle i'm like
he was doing this to see around the top
what the [ __ ]
i know dude it was i was i had my
fingers crossed that whole [ __ ] trip
saying a flight simulator trying to get
me home safe
does these any of these air conditioners
you have right now
sure have bluetooth in them bluetooth
yeah we can turn ours on from our phone
when we know we're coming i think
the new one does real nice i think the
new one does
really i don't even use the remote i'm
old school i want to go up and [ __ ]
as soon as you order the dessert hit the
[ __ ] ac
oh i leave ours i leave ours cooking
really yeah when you go out yeah
just on all day i turn it down like i
step it down to keep it cool you never
lose the room
you don't want to lose the room you lose
the room you're bad news trying to
retake that [ __ ]
that's like [ __ ] they eat them it's
like taking normandy again it ain't easy
so i lower it you know i put it on like
a schedule like i keep it at 62. keep it
at the coldest
it's like chilly keep it at the coldest
and then we'll leave i might bump it up
to like
70 or something just that means you
don't do the whole apartment
so the hallway's never air-conditioned
no
but we don't we're not in the hallway
we're only in the hallway when i walk to
it's literally the width of this table
like what am i doing in the hallway i
don't know and it's just weird you're
closing doors behind you
it's haircut you got to close the door
there's air conditioning holy would pass
out before he hit the kitchen
babe i'm going to the kitchen you need
to
[Laughter]
come back he's got a shirt wrapped
around his head like he's in the [ __ ]
desert
she's all i could find
you gotta roll the toilet paper you know
the remote
it's like a quiet place um
all right let's see here this is from
dalton you or anyone in your family ever
done a competitive eating competition
that's god that's a hard no for me i did
in elementary school or high school
but i can't remember what i ate i don't
think it was pies
because i feel like that would have
stuck in my brain
maybe watermelon oh
they were big at the swim club growing
up yeah a watermelon eating contest that
i vividly remember my brother being in
but that's more like a game for like
that was like a game like a contest for
like kids yeah we did
some kind of assembly in high school or
something like that i can't remember
watch how much this kid can eat
come one come all just lunch
[Laughter]
i can't remember they're running down
the hallway foley's going for the record
huh with something but no that's garbage
sure yeah it's a trash uh this is from
aoc is there any classy name that ends
with the letter y
no toby toby
henry's pretty classy i'll get henry i
never thought of
i think they're thinking more of like
the billy bobby tommy johnny
sandy like the girls names and why you
know that kind of stuff is tough
yeah yeah it's a tough blog booby
toby stuff but that's not your
government name it is not
it is a nickname that's a nickname uh
yeah thomas did you ever wear
emo stuff did you ever wear like the
underlying ever paint your fingernails
no [ __ ] now eyeliner no black trench
coat
no no no i was like a element t-shirt
kind of guy
element t-shirt did you ever spike your
hair did you ever bleach your hair
no way this hair's money maker baby
shit's fire
i don't know about that there's a
tobyville there is a bit of
there's toby time which i found out
which is i can't wrap my head around
the [ __ ] how that's working toby time
yeah two of everything's two minutes and
it takes four hours
four hours to the point where we were we
were doing the show and they say i'm
like i'm gonna have to have a sick he's
like oh just wait for me it'll be two
minutes and i'm like
dude you have there's four cameras to
break down there's [ __ ] suitcases
that pack up
you're gonna be [ __ ] two hours to
disappear in the airport too wow that's
always fun where's toby
well you guys are like you guys are
weird about that though you gotta like
you have to be
you have to hold each other's belts it's
like you're in kindergarten no i leave
him all the t's always ten paces behind
me
staring at the window pulling up to six
yeah
pulling up your pants um
yeah i hey i'm efficient man i stick and
i move no time for lollygagging let's go
that's what i do all right it's a
businessman by the way i applied for tsa
pre-check
for just you or all of us i can't apply
for you what do you tell us
i i am telling you right now all right
well i gotta do it
okay hey flock of seagulls what's going
on with the hair over there
yeah wait wait if we get it is totally
gonna cover that
uh that'll come up in our quarterly
meeting
yeah she's covering it i'm making an
executive decision
okay because i spent all my money that's
why
i really only gave my knees 20 bucks
um all right this one this one's from
william
ever have a parent as a substitute
teacher
dude that's gotta [ __ ] suck
i don't think i don't think we had that
i don't even think kids had
oh one kid uh his
he was his mom was our spanish teacher
and she
[ __ ] sucked everybody hated her
really
every dude like i knew who she was be it
was like you knew her before you got it
were they in class with you because i
had that i didn't
know i had a teacher in elementary
school
where her daughter was was in cl was in
the class
there's got to be some kind of [ __ ]
you know yeah there's got to be
something going on
what's that conflict of interest yeah
it's like cops hooking up
yeah i'm listening it's gotta be frowned
upon
yeah i mean how can you unbiasedly right
or wrong you know what i mean like
grade your kid oh i'd be [ __ ] well my
mom was [ __ ] i thought they were more
dicks be on easy street no i don't know
the coaching was was was tough too with
the coach's son or whatever you know
what i mean i deal with that
he stunk yeah it was all the coach's kid
always got looks that he shouldn't have
been getting yeah
he shouldn't have you got coach's son
vibes yeah my dad
t-ball really the cubs
i heard they were good back in the day
until the scandal
my dad taught or a coach did you guys
ever do did you get hit by a ball
and kid pitch i'm sure not that i
remember though
dude we had a kid hit so many players on
our team we had to forfeit
really i got beamed in the elbow bro he
hit like nine kids
yeah and they wouldn't take him out we
no we never i don't remember that
also i do remember we got in a fight in
hockey after the game the game was over
i think we were i think we won and we
ran up the [ __ ] points on them and
like the other teeth
the other team was like mad or whatever
and
the parents got mad that's what like
they were like this is a sh you know
what i mean the parents got mad at the
coach for being like
yo you're still let you're still running
up the [ __ ] it's like nine nothing or
whatever you know like the nine point
rule champions don't quit yeah baby
we're going ham
and i they didn't let something happened
it was in
that was always a big place to where it
would throw down the
slapping of the hands oh because you
would hit the other or like you would
shoulder the kick especially on skates
when you had gloves on
of course you would [ __ ] yeah and
it was always like the coaches like
don't nobody do anything and we made it
halfway through that line and the
[ __ ]
heater broke out of the like 10 years
nobody's doing that until i make a move
dude we were like 10 and we're like
going at it at center ice that's awesome
and [ __ ] these parents
maybe lasted about two seconds before
they start [ __ ] peeing off
each other dude they're falling down the
bleachers and [ __ ] now we're all
stopping we turn around like ah what the
[ __ ] people are like mom dad relax
women were fighting it was a scene all
right
pillow fight what are we talking about
yeah that's garbage man yeah it's tough
getting thrown out of a game
is a tough look yeah yeah never
never um
this one's from big head gonzalez uh a
long time listener first time patron you
guys
ever disagree with a family member until
you both get a couple drinks
and then they start making sense i mean
i found that feels like every argument i
think ever
drunk especially with my family we get
we yeah we get drunk and we
i serious no i see what you say yeah
well that also happens that's pretty
true it's true
it's true you see it when you're zoomed
out that you're like
they're not listening to one another
they're just like no they're just on a
broken record
and that's a tough look when you're
having a conversation with a with a
relative
and like you don't agree or don't give a
[ __ ] yeah no
no you're right you're right true true
try to go to the bathroom
are the hors d'oeuvres out i think they
just dropped desserts see you later
[ __ ] yeah brutal later i've got a one
time
uh i was at my i was at a party and i
was just walking by to like get a beer
like i was walking by the kitchen
and i was like you know uh like a lot of
my own there's just like a big group of
[ __ ] people they're like
yeah like that new york liberal over
there i'm like i'm not getting pulled in
from [ __ ] 15 feet
away you guys are just looking for an
enemy going over there doing [ __ ]
feet
get them yeah right there's [ __ ]
hitting bats and bear spray
[Laughter]
um all right let's see what else do we
got here
um this one's from thomas you guys ever
throw garbage out the car window
in the 80s the 80s dude it was
crazy you just launch a bag of mickey
d's out the window like it was nothing
that's just what you did well i don't
understand it man looking back it's so
bad it's crazy dude we used to a family
that's when it was like the styrofoam
i'm talking the whole bag oh cups drinks
dude you would eat a family one of the
kids just throwing a disposable cooler
out the window
dude a family of four or five would be
eaten in like a minivan and then just
like
out the [ __ ] passenger window doing
80. oh
crazy crazy shirt cannon full of fries
i don't understand why that was more
exciting they turned it around in the
90s it was like this is
yeah i remember being a kid at some
points being like this
i've seen the commercials that say this
is bad but
[ __ ] launch it meanwhile now
recycling's a lie they're just boxing it
up dumping in an ocean i say throw it in
the streets
t-bone anarchist over here this guy
doesn't like it they're gonna be doing
street cleaning even more
sounds like more commie talk to me
no i'm trying to try to make sure we got
some good union jobs out there
that's very true those styrofoam big mac
things
you do you remember those or you too
little remember i don't know
also i was always i stayed in the
chicken nuggies lane
i got their fast food i still tend to to
be honest
ain't nothing wrong with a couple of
select chicken shrimps five piece meal i
don't put you out
uh mcnugget only one for me that's my
girl right have you had the strips
i don't think i might i i mean maybe
when i was younger
it's too much too much mcdonald's
chicken for me man
they're good they're real i don't think
i trusted them they
they they select about it they're just
mcnuggets glued together
it's like nerds rope for chicken it's
chicken rope
and what do you think of hamburger you
know any you know any cows are in a
hamburger
everybody says this dumb [ __ ] quote
what are you 60 minutes
there's forty thousand different cows in
one hamburger a thousand
a thousand maybe forty thousand of the
ones you eat
[Laughter]
i like to spread it around
[Laughter]
there's bloodlines that aren't living on
because of you
it's got a whole family of cats
they say that's bad for disease purposes
mad cow disease
mad cow that's a great seinfeld line
it's not our fault these cows are crazy
um all right this one's from christian
never been read you've ever
been in a bar with you ever been in a
bar bathroom with no sink
i can't that the the grossest bathroom
i've ever been in was this place it used
to be
it was the oakford inn and then scruples
it was a [ __ ]
strip club in our neighborhood our
neighborhood you know
with like 15 minutes away or whatever
scruples
drupals like a superman villain scruples
yeah i don't know
it ain't a nice establishment it was the
place where you would go and then like
you'd see it like you'd be going like
college or whatever when you're like
home for
[ __ ] christmas it's gotta have dolls
or satin or something in it
squirtles the fantasy
show bar scruple such a touch
yeah scribble sounds like an evil puppet
don't you come over to scruples scruples
wants to play
yeah it was uh it wasn't the classiest
place but they had one of those purples
now
they had uh scruples
they had one of those people little doll
gives you chlamydia
[Laughter]
murderers to support his kid
[Laughter]
um they had that reusable towel
in bath hand somebody posted that not
that long ago
on twitter or something like it was like
the communal like cloth
towel that you would use i remember i
wouldn't even go in there dude
i remember using one of those way
too [ __ ] recently oh how did they
make it
out of the 50s i don't know i definitely
remember using one in the early 2000s in
new york
they i mean it's insane dude it's insane
they can't be around now with the
[ __ ] code
oh my god that's what we know they could
be flourishing
what for all we know they could be flat
i mean i don't think so but
it's neither here nor there dude those
things they were the gross
every dude it's still stuck that's the
grossest thing ever
that's gotta be that's disgusting but i
think in theory you pull it down
and then it goes up so do you pull down
a clean
you're supposed to but how much could be
in there i don't know i don't know i'm
not
fully sure how it works and they are
gross disgusting and there's no way to
know that it's not just looping back
around like a treasure that's what i
think
it is it's just like yeah
dude in this place it was so it was one
of the ones where the stage was only
like [ __ ] three and a half inches
high because it had low drop ceiling
it was tough tough luck
one of those one of those drop ceilings
definitely had a water stain on oh well
they were painted black we were classy
have you ever
have you ever gotten anything from the
guy that works in the bathroom like you
ever grabbed a mint or anything like
that or
some gum or i mean you know me quite
well right
do you think i'm taking communal
bathroom mints one of my buddies took a
snickers from
one time i was like what are you nuts
i've done maybe a piece of gum here and
there some of the good ones have burnies
single lucy's
what they got oh yeah some of the places
i i
frequent they got they'll have like a
pack of they'll have like a pack of
lights and a pack of
new ports or whatever yeah so some more
rope guys
lights um yeah so you can go in there
and grab one or two you know
if you're not if you're not like fully
on the bernie's those have to be going
away right
those guys unfortunately i would assume
can't just have some dude and some
guy in the band yeah the ladies have
them
i think the ladies bathrooms have i mean
it'd be a woman i guess
a matrix a [ __ ] christmas mom
yeah yeah that's when you find out what
did he call her she was something a
maitre d
no matter d is the guy that seats you
that runs the restaurant runs the floor
remember what it was i think it's a
maitre d
no something but whatever yeah i guess
the girls have it too
you never what about a vending machine
in the bathroom you ever get anything
out of there
i think i've gotten a couple of rubbers
back in the day when you were jammed up
or whatever
um yeah i think
con i mean what else would you when you
were a kid and you saw those you thought
they were interesting for like two
seconds and you're like what the [ __ ] i
would try not to aspirin and [ __ ]
rubbers
i would try not to make eye contact with
them
[ __ ] people peep a quick look right
over
um well in new york they give the ones
out
the nyc they give you sure fishbowl yeah
those are all right
so i've gone in i think i've gone and
used the bathroom and on the way out
grabbed a hand oh okay not out of the
actual vending machine i'm sure i have
i remember doing that at some point is
lifestyle a prank brand
is like the whole point of those that
they're guaranteed to break i don't know
listen a big man shooting his mouth off
yeah right i don't know i don't know i
never had like a reliable contraceptive
i think i would do lifestyles ribbed for
my pleasure
put it on backwards hey she's on her own
[Laughter]
she's in the other room what are you
talking about i'm doing a dress
rehearsal
is that what you're saying that you're
so big that [ __ ] lifestyle
no no i'm just saying that they break
they're like [ __ ] pinatas those
things ah get out of here they're all
the same
yeah i never had too big i never had a
brand where i was pretty good
baggy plenty of room
plenty of room to stretch out it's like
delta premiere in there
three dicks in this condom
[Laughter]
um i never had a brand where i was like
a go-to
no i was always whatever want to get out
of here
karma drink i know this really cool bar
there's free cigarettes in the bathroom
um all right this one's from josh you
know anyone that can open a bottle of
beer with their teeth
i saw a woman do this not long ago
front row at a show she [ __ ] where
he in new york here in new york yeah
front row attractive lady too
front row rooftop show during the
pandemic
her and her boyfriend popped one off
jesus [ __ ] christ that's no
good my boy pat does it and we're like i
think he cracked the tooth once we're
like all right you gotta [ __ ]
yeah i don't like that you gotta stop it
i'm not even good with the lighter
dude my wife has to do it for me very
emasculated
i know twist off you [ __ ] that's a beer
can
i can't get it anything like that and
doing the teeth doing the spit that can
go all the way down and pull it back
i mean what who's doing what is this big
daddy who's doing that
no one's doing that did you did you have
any gleekers
gleekers yeah you know like the gleek
that's where you just it's like you move
your tongue in a way that spits the spit
out of you oh
those kids no no the lizard people
yeah no way i remember i can do it at
will
you want to see it no you spit [ __ ]
chicken salad on me the other day i can
do it
but there was a kid that went to another
school
that the legend went the legend went he
can lift up his tongue and it would just
shoot out like a constant stream
my buddy used to always say oh you see
he went down he went to grade school
with a minute
one day we're at a gas station sure [ __ ]
this kid's there
he runs up he's like do it kid knew
exactly what he was talking about he
turned to the side just went
a a stream a continuous stream of
whatever that juice is
spit just kept going he could do it at
will as long as you want it
x-men yeah gleekers an x-men yeah that's
what it's called it's called leaking hey
lightly and hey lightly annoy this evil
villain will you
[Laughter]
please smackdido's coming gross them out
[Laughter]
i think i saw we had a guy we had a guy
who could puke on demand
and uh that's a good time when you're in
seventh grade i gotta tell you
could puke on demand would he have to
stick his fingers on his throat
all ab work just ew yeah
damn what's he doing now i know he's
doing pretty well i think
get out of a couple of checks that way
what
yeah he would be like i'm sick and then
he would not in the place but like
outside he would like
act like he got sick we would get
himself sick
and be like i don't feel well then run
outside and puke and we're like we gotta
do this and they're like get out of here
i mean it was for like a slice of pizza
and a wild cherry coke but
yeah anyway it wins a win you're
speaking my language
yeah excuse me wild cherry pepsi cherry
coke yeah yeah sorry
you're not a pepsi guy while cherry
pepsi had aldo's for sure that growing
up that's where we went
yeah get the plague um
what was i just gonna oh we had a could
you have a kid that could make himself
fart
i had a kid that could light his farts
on fire anybody can do that
i did that two weeks ago yeah he did it
in the plane the other day did it on
stage
uh we had a kid who could make himself
fart you would hear him suck
air in his [ __ ] and he then doing we
made him do it in the pool one time he
just sucked and then like [ __ ]
like just liquid [ __ ] everywhere oh what
though
not in the pool also we had a kid that
had webbed feet
found that out when i was like eight
holy [ __ ]
tough dude that was a bad day at camp
good job
that kid came in the pool we were like
what in the [ __ ]
is that dude yikes hey aquaman
yeah [ __ ] hey you you hang out in the
hot dog
you would think those kids are good
swimmers but i don't think they are i
don't think it's enough
i mean it's not like a flipper it's just
like a [ __ ] you know
little piece of skin oh man he had ugly
toes too
i'm gonna switch subject
we gotta do one or two more then we
gotta get out of here that's gonna make
me throw up i promise
um let's see
okay let's get out of here on this one
this one's from michael first question
asked have you ever had a homeowner's
insurance claim that you delay getting
the work done and just deposit the check
into your bank account so you have a few
exposed pipes or drywall in your home
i didn't know you were allowed to do
that what you're allowed to do that with
the insurance money yeah you decide on
whether or not you
i don't know how really yeah i don't
think you have to get the work you can
choose that's why like people who crash
their car
they're like yeah i got a thousand
twelve hundred dollars from whatever and
they just sort of like i'll just drive
around with a banged up [ __ ] car
could 1200 sitting in my on my head i
need it you got a pistol i to pay rent
something like that yeah yeah we never
had any insurance issues
ever growing we've had some flooding and
stuff like that my parents had to deal
with some [ __ ]
now they always they always get it done
right away yeah they want it done
that's pretty garbage man yeah yeah but
i don't know
if i had something like that if i could
use the 12 honda and i'm like i'm not
having that's 12.
i'm not having something 30 grand oh
yeah yeah
patch that up for five i'm sitting tight
25 jihads yeah oh yeah you always go
you go low or you get take the low
estimate you turn in the high one you go
low
oh yeah they go high we go low exactly
arm and a leg i'm gonna like they're
charging yeah
they say they want three guys out here
get your uncle steve to do it ah
good times here kip that was a fun one
buddy great family episode gang we love
you
very much you guys are amazing kippy
what do you got for me you want the kids
out there to know
uh kevin ryan comedy on all social media
follow the ru garbage pages we're almost
at 10k
on both i believe twitter and instagram
so check those out
uh and then you know youtube uh itunes
and patreon we [ __ ] love every single
one of you guys thank you so much
tour's cooking we appreciate every
single person
that has come after you see us live it's
cool to meet everybody cool to meeches
take pictures
you guys have been [ __ ] absolutely
amazing and we [ __ ]
greatly greatly appreciate it and we're
looking forward to the [ __ ]
the the rest of this run yeah guys we
have a we have a lot of shows coming up
a lot of shows coming up if you're not
familiar it's uh you know we do some
stand-up and then we play ayg with the
crowd which is turning out to be [ __ ]
boxing so fun
the [ __ ] audience is having a blast
we're having a really good time
uh and we also have shirts on the road
that are only available on the road
so come out and see us gang we love you
we'll see you next week